in Crossville Tennessee God has his very
own treehouse God told Noah to build an
ark he told Horace Burgess to build a
treehouse God's treehouse in 1993
Minister Horace Burgess heard the Word
of God and God said to him if you build
the treehouse you will never run out of
materials which is kind of like a pretty
minimal promise but Horace started
building piece by piece out of scrap
wood and leftover building materials
it's supported by six different trees
mainly supported by one giant white oak
it's 97 feet tall or a better way to put
that as 10 stories tall took over
285,000 nails when you walk into it you
have no idea where you're gonna end up
this treehouse includes secret hallways
some hidden rooms spiral staircases at
the heart of this is the sanctuary /
basketball court / dance floor /
whatever else you needed to be and when
you get to the top and you look down at
the fields below you will see the word
Jesus written out in flowers planted by
Burgess because as burgess himself says
from up there the view is heavenly so he
spent the last 14 years crafting this
incredible treehouse but sadly well God
doesn't have a fire code crossville
tennessee does in 2012 the minister's
treehouse the greatest treehouse ever
built was closed down you can in fact
call the crossville tennessee fire
marshal and politely ask them that they
reopened the treehouse and in horace
burgesses own word
it's not for him it's for everybody and
God keeps watch the treehouse also
inspires its visitors one such visitor
was so taken that he went and created
stained-glass windows which were then
installed into the treehouse as well the
bells of the treehouse are a set of
empty acetylene gas tanks that have been
strung up by rope and when pulled chimed
together in a kind of loaf I'd DIY
heavenly harmony